[Music]
and they know everything news committed
by Mac dong black-market mobile phone
location data was tied to a triple
murder
black market mobile phone data it's a
Chinese cell phone company Oh No Joe's
in the video no no he's in one of those
[ __ ] up conspiracy videos right now
cuz it's good this one gets weird okay
in Texas some plain closed
federal agents walked into a Nissan
dealership and they claimed they had a
warrant to apprehend Ramon Hutchinson
who was wanted for failure to appear in
court on a first-degree drug drug charge
and they suspected that he would be
there somehow they're just kind of new
and so there's a family of five that was
there and the owner of the dealership
agreed to lift a minute because they're
like okay your federal agents cool yeah
however these guys were not federal
agents they were a person aiding the
police they were two bounty hunters and
they were pretending to be federal
agents so they could get in easily right
yes sir but don't worry they get theirs
is it illegal to be an officer on
Halloween of course don't be
impersonating you can if two guys had a
bullet and a bulletproof vest and they
said they were federal agents I would
have been like nah that's right where's
your suit and then you give him some
candy
yep so as they approached him the the
bounty hunters pulled out their guns and
grabbed him from behind attempted to
restrain him and he pulled a gun from
his belt they all three shot at each
other inside of the inside the
dealership and everybody died years
before there was a video everybody died
there was a video there was like 16
shots or some [ __ ] I was a crazy number
of Scheible Mike everybody does
everybody does everybody just the three
people armed all right yeah yeah people
no no Nissan did a diner I want in the
standoff died oh good Oh cuz you
mentioned a family of five
oh no they made it and then I would even
mention no I'll just wanted to be the
seniors they were inside of the Sentra
well what kind of cars were on the floor
a really nice rav4 actually they're
inside the central you know what they
have the sensor on this show we got a
very tasteful quest yeah good for you
man they were in the champagne Ultima
hunts right so how do you guys think
that the Bounty Hunter's found these
people Oh data it's exactly right
triangulated that [ __ ] Wow that's
scurry that legal no hold on actually I
think that there's unfortunately the FCC
is not really checking into this [ __ ] so
it's almost like yeah sure do you think
wow yeah so it's impairing the data on
people's phones are being sold your data
of my data
Geo's data everybody don't have a phone
yes oh yeah cuz we say you don't where
we get Apple phones yes I say [ __ ] no
our data is being sold to people like
these guys so so like like if they
needed to pick you up because you
skipped a bail bond or some [ __ ] like
they're going to be able to triangulate
your position because your mobile
carrier already sold your shelves right
is that way shame yes people have to
have those burner phones probably
absolutely they don't want to get
triangulated
it's actually pretty hot yeah so AT&T
t-mobile Sprint and Verizon all sold
their customers real-time location D
yeah oh you said AT&T I did Bob no no no
congratulations everyone else's [ __ ] so
so it too middleman companies they make
that call themselves location
aggregators and they basically provide
access to like a wide range of other
parties right like used car sales man
what why would they need what I mean
crazy on him yeah if I'm a used car
salesman okay no just and I have a lead
on you because you you may be called my
dealership and you left your information
because you're interested in purchasing
a car that's what's called establishing
a lead right and then they can bug you
wherever the [ __ ] you are and and call
you in on all sorts of [ __ ] and that's
why they buy your data that actually
happened to me is that because I was
inquiring I accidentally sent a mass
email to all my local Volvo dealers
looking for a specific Volvo because I
was using this service I didn't know
would do that we just had Volvo now all
these ads are gonna pop up on your phone
true you're trying to give a to your ass
but this is only through email and yet
somehow they they were texting my number
saying like hey I know you were
interested in a Volvo like how the [ __ ]
did you get my number
that's [ __ ] scary so yeah basically
they can also sell your information to
bounty hunters so if I'm looking for you
for whatever reason you skipped out on a
court date or some [ __ ] they sell that
to bounty hunters and then Bears know
exactly where the [ __ ] you weight it
shoot back at them right I know is any
bad thing
what's a privacy thing it is a privacy
thing but if you're not doing [ __ ] and
you're an upright citizen no but if
you're not doing [ __ ] you're an upright
citizen and the bounty hunter mistake
ins you check it out and you get a
broken leg and then you get embarrassed
in front of all your co-workers you get
sent to jail and then all this [ __ ]
happens or just general privacy I mean
there's just yeah things can happen you
just don't know if I was to sell to a
company exactly where geo is and here's
her income level and she makes this much
money and you can probably target your
ads at her specifically when she's in
these locations by you know turning on
[ __ ] computer screens or whatever in
selling particular branded ads to oh it
works on me all the time I know you're
more thankful about it huh yeah it's
already invasive enough as it is where
you you went to a web site and then it
goes on your phone yeah it's an
Instagram ads where you talk about it
right so this is where it goes awry
right like this guy got killed because
they knew exactly where the [ __ ] he was
but the funny thing is why did he shoot
at the bounty hunter well he doesn't
know who they are
he doesn't
yeah or you just he probably thought
they were just crazy with guns drawn in
fun well they were they were dressed as
as a federal agent oh yeah what fake
badges they want right exactly they
weren't so he was right to be like what
the [ __ ]
well damn what a [ __ ] mix-up man yeah
so and they can ping your phone so what
happened we're just just prior to the
murder is they paying this person's
phone like a [ __ ] on it to make sure
that they're there to triangulate where
they were survived they would have gone
for murder
I don't know I mean that that would
probably that's up to yeah like what
charges and all that stuff they were
personating police officers I don't know
that's a good question what were they
going after them for again the drug
thing yeah yeah so you didn't show up to
court and they usually you know go after
people that don't show up show up to
court because they're not paying for the
bail like these bounty hunters just on
their own time they went to these data
sellers and got this data or was it
through that bounty hunter company and
they're the ones that are getting the
data yeah it's probably that I mean
we'll think about it a lot of bail bail
companies have bounty hunters or they
hire about bounty hunters because it
like it goes in handy when our money
back yeah like let's say you get in
trouble you go to jail you call me I'm
your I'm your Baylor like I bail you out
I pay the the majority of the funds
right and I go you gotta show up to
court it's my job to make sure you show
up to court because if you don't then
the bail is forfeited and it [ __ ] me
yeah so that's why I got a higher bounty
hunters to come get you in that
situation they're probably gonna do
anything they can to find you here's
what a lot of people are pissed about so
right now the FCC has an open
investigation into the sale of all of
our data and here's what here's what the
FCC says they said what I'm hearing as
described in this reporting about the
shooting is concerning this story
continues to throw troubling actions by
a number of entities throughout the paid
attract ecosystem if true this again
points to the alarming public safety
implications of making geolocation data
available for purchase it is long past
time that the FCC complete any
investigations and hold all wrongdoers
countable but when when right and how do
they even know who sold what who leaked
what well they have they they know that
this this data is being sold they just
don't know me all know exactly we should
know huh yeah but I don't want to read
all those pages I just want to hit agree
and then just yeah get the app well they
pretty much corner you into a green
because if not then you can't use the
service like if you want histogram and
you better say yes and then it's like oh
they're actually selling my information
and then they make you feel like they
really care that you read it or not
because some of those you you you have
to scroll through the whole thing
because or else they'll accept won't
even show up yeah so then you kind of
feel like oh they have my best interests
in mind but it's also like what exactly
are you doing like even when people talk
about Alexa and like her listening to us
like I'm gonna talk about anything shady
like I'm not trying to overthrow the
government like there's a privacy
problem but at the same time is the
everyday person avoiding a drug charge I
mean they could find ways to advertise
to you so if they hear you like you're
talking about shampoo all the time or
whatever then I follow your ads wolf
yeah don't start being on market all of
these times I'm more worried about the
this information getting into the wrong
people's hands slippery slope cuz like
let's say I'm a burglar mm-hmm i buy
data to figure out the richest people in
my neighborhood and then i know where
they're at all the time i could ping
their phone if they're not at home I
could go and rob their house it sounds
like that
there's just oh man with with this like
goldmine of information you could do a
lot of evil with it so that's what's
kind of dangerous that's where I'm at
yeah cuz the Kardashians have a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of security all the time but
not me I still happen in Paris where she
got oh yeah that's right I also don't
think it's good to just trust people
that you don't know you've never met
they're at some company and you're like
well I'm probably not saying anything
bad or doing anything that bad so I
trust it yeah I just don't like that
that feels weird to me I've never met
you I'm not care but then after talking
to you Steve you kind of changed my mind
on the whole like freedom of speech and
privacy thing cuz I'm like yeah it could
be a very slippery slope and like I
could be imprisoned just for nothing
round you know I mean
yeah I don't wish it was like this I
just don't I just see where it could go
and I would love to push back but you
still gotta licks it alright well Lola
let's say 1884 man everyone right now
Alexa play dancing queen in their home I
hope that she did because there you can
have a little bit of fun clean and I
mean we just got one of those guys it's
pretty fun it's a blast great speakers
[Music]